I went on America's Got Talent and got
kicked off the show it told me I'd never
make it as a performer and then I
started doing YouTube and then
everything took off and when your
passion is what you do for a living very
hard to not become a workaholic no if
you if you're not happy with the person
you are today I wondered percent believe
that you can change she's an American
violinist singer songwriter composer and
performing artist her music video
crystallized was the 8th most watched
video in 2012 as of July 2016 her
YouTube channel has over 8 million
subscribers and over a billion views
she's Lindsey Stirling and here is my
take on her top 10 rule to success rule
number 2 is my personal favorite I make
sure to stick around all the way to the
item for some special bonus clips and as
always as Lindsay's talking if you said
something that really resonates with you
please leave it in the comments below
put quotes around it so other people can
be inspired as well enjoy
[Music]
I think honestly being true yourself is
the absolute key to being successful in
this kind of a model because you can't
fake authenticity
you can't fake loving something and
honestly to any I think any artistic
form a medium you have to work so hard
to get you know get your stuff hurt or
seen and so if you don't absolutely love
it you will burn yourself out and the
only way I'm able to do what I do is you
know I'm almost a workaholic because I
love what I'm doing and it's okay like I
because I'm enjoying it because I love
the people that I work with it's you
know it doubles as work and Recreation
and if I didn't love it it would be
impossible I went on America's Got
Talent and got kicked off the show it
told me I'd never make it as a performer
and then I started doing YouTube and
then everything took off and so to be
able you know to be invited back to one
of the biggest shows in America and a
show that I got kicked off of and then
to be invited back it was a really cool
experience just because a lot of people
don't get the chance to redo a moment of
their life that was very devastating and
to be able to go back on that stage and
do it the way I wanted to do it and to
be able to give the performance I wanted
it was really awesome I mean there were
also critiques on the show the judges
were not always nice with you right was
it like judgement day where he says like
hi I'm back and this time I'm started
you know kind of it wasn't I hope that
my fans that other people saw it that
way in a way of like you know you can't
let anyone else tell you who you are and
how good you are because everyone has
their own opinions but I hope that they
see that wow the same way Lindsay didn't
listen to them and she went back and was
able to prove them wrong like I can do
that like if someone at schools mean to
me it doesn't mean that I'm a bad person
it doesn't mean I'm a dork or a loser
you know I can I can become whoever I
want to be and I hope that people see
that because that moment proves that to
me you know and it's it's true I wish so
when I first started I wish I had
realized that people were the most
important thing to me because there was
a time you know I I'm such a hard worker
and when your passion is what you do for
a living very hard to not become a
workaholic and there was a time when I
just almost lost sight of everything
that was most important to me because I
was working so hard and I was pushing so
hard for these these dreams and these
goals and everything I wanted in life
and my life started to look very gray
and colorless and I just I realized I
had lost a lot of depth because I wasn't
making time for those most important
things which are my family and you know
the people in my life or someone that
maybe needed me at a time but I was too
busy to even notice and those are the
things that you can't you can't fulfill
your full passion whether it's through
music or art or dance if you've lost
sight of the things that make you a real
person and I had to like refine myself
almost like wow what is it that makes me
me and once I refined that it's like
everything else came together again I
was able to write again I was able to
create but without those things then you
lose sight of everything I think like
you said every single artist goes
through that like and I think a lot of
times you think that the great writers
are the people they just write hit after
hit after hit and they do but it's also
because they get through all the
terrible songs first and I mean I think
that's kind of every single artists
story and and I mean I love to talk when
people ask what's your best advice for
you know upcoming musician all right
anybody I think it's that you have to be
able to rise from the failures is what
makes a successful person because
everybody's going to have mishaps
they're going to fall down and it's you
know the people that continuously pick
themselves up that are the ones that are
going to find their voice make it
whatever you want to call it I love how
for this record you had fans actually do
little videos and talks about what they
were brave enough to do in life so for
you what was the moment you realized
you're brave enough to kind of just do
this full-time and go right after your
passion oh um you know I think it's once
I discovered YouTube I mean I had
already been going for it with full
force you know and what I was kind of
wondering if I had what it took to make
it and I was really discouraged at times
because everywhere I went I just kept
being told like no you're not good
enough like you
you know and I can be really
discouraging and so even though I was
going for it I was kind of like in the
back of my mind just really scared like
am I going to make it I don't know and
and then when I just finally discovered
YouTube and I put up my first video I
just felt so empowered and so excited
because I was like whoa finally
something's working and that's when I
was like I'm gonna you know I don't know
how this is not going to work out and
I'm going to chase this with everything
I've got and that's when I was like boom
and what about the appreciation of
hip-hop and EDM which both played a role
in what in what you do musically when
did you when did you first encounter
those and how did you come to love them
um you know I really fell in love with
EDM when I first heard you know well I
mean I always liked like techno music I
felt like it was kind of for lack of a
better term it was like great white girl
dance music I've always loved to dance
and I was like all these beats I can
dance to this there's like it's not
quite as like doesn't need as much
groove as like hip hop did so that's why
I always like a DM and then I really
fell in love with it when I discovered
Skrillex especially bangerang that song
I was like oh my gosh I have to figure
out how I can pair the violin with this
weird dubstep stuff because it was so
fun and it made me want to move and
that's was the beginning you know it
never becomes I don't think it will ever
be like oh I don't care I don't care
anymore because I do care it's my art
it's my love is my passion and you know
certain comments you're able to like oh
whatever
but there's some comments that get you
in the place that you're a little bit
vulnerable trigger you they trigger you
think it's you oh you're like don't talk
about that that's actually something
that I care about like and I'm sensitive
to and so I think it's so important to
realize that especially like in YouTube
there is so much good but for some
reason it's easier to focus on the
negative because it just it gets you so
much more you get thousands of positive
comments right I mean I get everyone
name you're like oh dang it beautiful so
you know it's it's so true that you only
really do have one stage in your mind
that you can really focus on at one time
and so the good the bad they're going to
come and what are you going to focus on
am I going to like sit and do and like
respond
especially responding like if you
respond to the negative
that is a lot of times the one that you
want to respond to but it's like four am
I going to feed the good like am I going
to feed these people who keep coming
back and telling me really nice things
like that's where I should put my energy
that sir I should put my thoughts in
focus and it does take a lot of like you
know a concentration to do that
awareness to awareness that's the word
I'm looking for
but I think that's the key is just
there's good and bad all around us
everywhere and trying really hard to
focus on the good and let that feed you
you know every tour I like to try to
like step it up I want my fans that have
you know a lot of my fans come to
multiple shows and so I always want them
to be surprised when they come back I
don't want it to feel like the last ones
Easterling show you know and like oh
well you know been there done that
so I always try to do something that
I've never done before and this tour is
a lot of fun there's some new you know
tricks I have up my sleeve that I you
know I worked really hard to learn and
to master these these new skills but
anyway it's super excited about
I think the courage to be really open
about those you know some of the things
I've been through in the past all comes
from experiencing those things and when
I was going through say you know when I
was going through some of these things I
felt so alone and a lot of girls are
people do you feel like nobody can
understand you because a lot of these
problems deal with like isolating
yourself and feeling alone and one of
the things that really helped me have
the courage to change was that I
realized that I'm not alone like there's
actually people who understand me and
there's people who have actually
overcome this and it gave me hope and so
that's why I really strive to give a
positive message of hope about like you
know if you if you're not happy with the
person you are today I wondered percent
believe that you can change and so
that's what I like to hopefully share
with young girls and I would say that's
what gave me the courage to to share
well I've always played the violin ever
since I was six years old I begged for
lessons and I've always played and it
was actually when I was in college that
I kind of just realized one day that I
didn't love it anymore and I used to
love it and I specifically didn't study
music in school because I didn't ever
want to have the love of my music
yasmine so kind of broke my heart when I
was like I don't even enjoy this anymore
and so I started thinking okay what can
I do is here like invigorate my passion
like I started playing with bands I
started just anywhere I could go to kind
of try out new cell music and I've
always loved electronic music and it
just hit me one day I need to play and
write the kind of music that I am loving
right now and so I did and it just
brought it back to life for me it made
it so creative that I became a creator
not just a musician and that's I think
what just invigorated my passion
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because John Thoren
asked me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it down the comments below
and I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know what is Lyndsey
say that had the biggest impact on you
which rule did you enjoy the most
what are you going to take from her
message to immediately apply to your
life or business please leave it in the
comments and I'm going to join in the
discussion
finally one think of a quick shout-out
to Steph reveron steps thank you so much
for picking up a copy of my book your
one word and sending in that picture of
you at the cafe reading it I hope you're
enjoying it and getting a lot of value
from it so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is let's love
I'll see you soon
so say my kids look up to like Taylor
Swift and they want to you know get a
little guitar and be Taylor Swift
my parents used to take me to Orchestra
concerts and so that was my version of a
rock star like oh my gosh I have to get
one of those wooden things and but yeah
I played classical violin all growing up
and I started to just I had gotten burnt
out and I wanted to love it again and so
I started experimenting with all
different sorts of music and I found out
that I absolutely loved EDM and
electronic dance and dubstep music and
nobody no record labels thought I was
worthwhile or that my project was
marketable and so I started doing it
myself on YouTube and that's when it
just kind of whoa I guess it is
marketable yeah kind of discovered I
guess I surround like my crew my furher
I surround myself of really great people
I was best work ruined believed I mean
honestly just say one day I wanted to be
crazy and like went out got drop and
they were all just be like well like
they would be so turned off and it was
just like Whitey's doing it probably
let's take the beer on my hand good
communal and see what's wrong with you
because they know me so well and as soon
as protect me and help me as well I
wasn't like I have always been a very
optimistic upbeat person when I first
came to college it was a time that I was
trying to figure out Who am I what makes
me special and I started to find most of
my value in the fact that I was thin for
several years I had no idea I had become
anorexic
and be places with people I cared about
but what I was thinking about was the
extra grease on pizza or the calories
that I knew were in that shake I just
was talking to my mom one day and I
broke down crying because I realized for
the first time I have problem and that
this is a normal people don't think like
this I finally realized I wasn't happy
anytime there's a change to be made you
have to realize that there's somewhere
else you want to be and I wanted
basically to be happy
that was her more important than be the
skinniest girl in a room once I realized
that there was a problem that's when I
could change I knew that I could be
happy again
[Music]